it is time to take a trip to selfie
world we announced the recent grand
opening
of the interacted diy photography studio
in town square
and now rocky is there live to show us
how to utilize the space and get the
shot what's going on rocky
hey okay am i cool yet how am i doing no
yes i will leave the coolness up to this
girl right here this is kaylee she is a
local employee
thank you so much for joining us we're
so fabulous thank you so
much as you can see i tried you have to
be a real athlete and your knees have to
be
yeah pretty good shape to really get the
poses down yeah but i want to bring up
the shot that i took
earlier before this segment um of the
vegas baby
booth is it up yet i hope so so as you
can see
there's a little glare in the in the
corner there and
that means i didn't do the lighting
correctly yeah
so we are having an exclusive lesson on
how to be
an influencer and get the instagramable
shot from kaylee so tell us how it works
how do we go
um with this photographer
there's two little knobs so the one on
the left
my left controls the whiteness and the
one on the right controls like the red
tones
so when you have a light like this you
want more of the red tones to be in it
and have it angled from here so that
when you're standing
look look or squatting here you're just
like
you want to just move and like if you're
down
effortless that just works i love it
okay and so fyi when you come to selfie
world you get
a ring light to take around with you and
that's so cool
everything so let's take a walk we're
gonna head down to another location
that i love here at selfie world and as
we walk i want to
ask you what's it like being a local
influencer um i kind of just
post my pictures and brands reach out to
you places reach out to me like this one
came here for opening night
it's honestly my favorite place because
there's so many places to take pictures
in here
yeah but yeah it's it's fun it's all
about getting the concepts yeah it's all
about self-love too yeah
it's a little confidence booster okay so
this one i really love this artwork is
actually done
by a local artist and it's like taking
an air it's taking a flight yeah and we
all miss traveling so this is a nice
place to live vicariously through
and i know we have my photo that i took
here if you can bring it up
you can bring it up they have a new
color light
that you can use and it changes the vibe
a little bit yeah really cool but before
we go we have 30 seconds left
just to explain how do we get the
perfect outfit
for selfie world basically um i tend to
go with more like neutral tones to like
jeans usually i wear white or black so
that every room you could
base something off of and usually look
at like what they have here
and like there's a yellow bike room over
there where
um yeah you can take pictures in the
dress or anything
exactly you want to bring some variety
so just fyi there are fitting rooms to
do that
so coming up in the four o'clock we're
going to take a look at a couple more of
these really cool places in here
listening back thank you thanks rocky
those are some good tips we're gonna
check in with you in the 4pm newscast